bonjour et bienvenue pour ce 5ème cours
de paléo mammalogie et enfin nous
attaquons le groupe auquel nous
appartenons tous les primates
alors comment reconnaît-on un fossile de
primate au premier coup d'oeil
eh bien les primates ce sont tout
simplement les mammifères qui ont la
vision la plus binoculaire quand vous
regardez un crâne de primates en face
vous voyez que ses deux yeux sont
orientés directement vers vous donc même
les carnivores qui ont aussi une vision
un peu près binoculaire n'ont pas les
yeux qui sont aussi fortement orientée
vers l'avant donc ça c'est typiquement
un caractère de primates et donc ça se
reflète sur le crâne par la position des
orbites dirigé antérieurement les
primates ont aussi un cerveau plus gros
que les autres mammifères et quand je
dis cerveau plus gros c'est un cerveau
plus gros que les mammifères de même
poids donc si vous prenez un petit
primate vous devais le comparer un petit
mammifère et il aura un cerveau qui sera
plus gros que ce petit mammifère et si
vous prenez un grand primate
il aura aussi un cerveau plus gros qu'un
mammifère aussi grand donc est
évidemment les primates on les reconnaît
à leur pouce opposable pouce opposable
qui permettent à ce petit bébé gibbon
vous voyez de sucer son pouce donc et
vous voyez même que les lémuriens aussi
sont capables de sucer leur pousse tout
ça c'est grâce au pouce opposable bien
sûr donc le fait de sucer son pouce
c'est aussi une scie napo morphy de
primates
alors évidemment on va me dire qu'il ya
des exceptions et il y en a il y a des
primates qui n'ont pas de pouce comme
les attelles par exemple donc vous voyez
ici l'at elle a perdu le pouce opposable
mais c'est bien le pouce opposable qui a
été perdu et pas autre chose quoi les
colobes aussi vous voyez on a une très
belle série ici qui nous on voit
finalement le pouce se réduire et tout
ça ça va de pair avec la braque à sion
donc les doigts
finalement forme un crochet et le pousse
devient inutile au final et vous pouvez
voir qu'il ya d'autres primates aussi
qui ont tendance à perdre les deux leurs
doigts comme le poteau le poteau qui
perd l'index
donc il a quatre doigts avec un pouce
opposable mais il n'a pas d'index
mais voilà globalement évidemment ce
primitivement il ya au moins un pouce
opposable sur les mâts et sur les pieds
et tous les ont tous les doigts ont des
ongles donc les ongles c'est aussi une
synapse murphy de primates les autres
mammifères ont des griffes ou des sabots
les primates ont des ongles ses ongles
donc ils ont ils se traduisent sur le
squelette par un aplatissement de la
phalange distale donc une phalange une
phalange distale aplatit et en forme de
pelle
c'est un trait typique des primates qui
reflète la présence d'ongles et
évidemment il ya des destinations morphy
de la dentition la plus importante
d'entre elles étant la perte de la
troisième à sisyphe donc les groupes
qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent à part les
dix proto dante avaient tous trois
paires d'incisives nous on n'a que deux
paires d'incisives deux perdent incisive
en eau et de perdre incisive en bas donc
résultant ont quatre incisive en tout
que ce soit sur la mâchoire supérieure
ou inférieure ceci est un caractère que
tous les primates ont en commun vous
pouvez compter votre nombre d'incisives
vous n'en avez que quatre
aussi alors un caractère un petit peu
plus compliqué c'est la bulle petrosa
halle où la bulle pétrole alors qu'est
ce que ça veut dire eh bien on a vu
pendant le cours des carnivores par
exemple que la bulle quand elle est
aussi fier chez les mammifères
elle est formée par l'anp tota panique
et l'hecto tympanique deux eaux qui sont
eux-mêmes dérivés chez les synapses id
de los angles l'air donc lançant guilers
des synapses heat s'est transformé en
hausse d'1 panique en taux et hautain
panique et c'est tantôt tapani qu'en
fait il est perdu chez les primates est
remplacé par le pétrole donc le pétrole
c'est l'os qui constitue le qui contient
l'oreille interne donc le la cochlée et
les canots semi circulaires sont
contenus dans l'eau spectre e et 7 e sp
tre en fait il va projeter un petit
processus qui va remplacer la bulletin
panique donc en fait la caisse de
résonance et l'organe de l'audition sont
toutes contenues dans le pétrin en fait
donc ça c'est une synapse morphy aussi
des primates la bulle petro halde oncle
tympanique les hautains panique sont
perdus et remplacé par le pétrole enfin
au niveau de la dentition les pelles et
les prix
as tu pas les pétro thebe les primates
sont tous buno dont tu donc pas d'ipso
dont 6 pas d'histoire d'ipso dont 6 chez
les primates tous les primates son but
no dont tu es bras qui donc il n'y a pas
d'autre y'a pas d'autres formes n'y a
pas de sceller non d'aussi on va voir
qu'il ya un groupe qui est lofo d'hondt
et c'est à peu près la seule
excentricité que les primates vont
s'offrir au final la seule excentricité
au niveau des molaires évidemment il y
aura d'autres excentricités dentaires
comme on va le voir et donc ça va de
pair avec un régime follivores
frugivores ou omnivore donc les les
êtres humains les babouins par exemple
sont omnivores
il y a des primates follivores comme les
bas comme les gibbons par exemple et il
ya des primates frugivores comme les
bras la plupart des autres primates en
réalité là tous les primates sont plus
ou moins frugivores tous les primates
vivent dans les arbres sauf les humains
ou du mois sont capables de grimper donc
je prends l'exemple des babouins qui ne
vivent pas particulièrement dans les
forêts ou dans les arbres mais les
babouins vivent dans les rochers et sont
capables de grimper
donc tous les primates sont capables de
grimper plus ou moins à part les humains
et tous les primates vivent en latitudes
tropicales sauf les humains et le
macaque à face rouge qui est ce macaque
très célèbre delà de l'île japonaise de
l'île d'hokkaido sur sur laquelle il
s'est laissé des babouins très connu ils
ont une grosse fourrure blanche une
phase tout rouge et ils se baignent dans
les sources d'eau chaude
créé par les volcans au japon voilà donc
vous avez certainement vu ça quelque
part et si vous n'avez pas si vous
n'avez jamais vu vous pouvez googlers
macaques à face rouge
ils sont très très connu et en voyant la
photo vous verrez tout de suite de quoi
je parle donc voilà tous les babouins
tous les primates sons tropicaux sinon à
part ces quelques exceptions l'humain et
le macaque à face rouge alors d'autres
caractères des primates qui sont un peu
qu'ils sont un peu moins fossiles is
able on va dire les primates sont parmi
les seuls mammifères qui ont une vision
tri chromate donc une vision à trois
couleurs
donc ici vous voyez la vision bichromate
typique des autres mammifères vision bi
chromatique qui a évolué à partir d'un
ancêtre en commun avec les autres
amniotes qui ont tous la capacité de
voir les couleurs ils ont quatre
différents types de cônes mais chez les
prix chez les l'ancêtre des mammifères
et bien s'il ya deux des quatre cônes
qui ont été perdus très probablement
parce que l'ancêtre commun de tous les
mammifères étaient un petit animal
nocturne donc rappelez-vous petit animal
nocturne et insectivores et bien quand
on est nocturne on n'a pas vraiment
besoin de voir les couleurs et les petit
insectivore que sont nos ancêtres ont
aimé ça leur a permis d'évoluer enfin ça
ouvert la voie à l'évolution d'une coque
l'esa ouvert la voie à l'évolution d'un
de bulbe olfactif beaucoup plus
développée donc il ya des sens qui ont
évolué pour compenser la perte de la vue
du à la nocturne alité mais les primates
ont ré évoluer finalement une vision tri
chromate est ce donc à partir d'une
duplication du gène qui code pour la
protéine qui permet de voir le vert
alors je juge ultra simplifié les gens
qui connaissent la physique derrière
tout ça vous engueuler mais voilà l'idée
c'est ça l'idée c'est l'idée est
derrière ça c'est qu'il ya un gène dont
qui colle pour le qui code pour le cône
qui permet de voir le verre chez les
autres animaux et se gênent en fait
c'est dupliquer et ensuite cette
duplication a muté de telle façon que ça
a donné un troisième caunes qui permet
de voir un peu plus le rouge donc c'est
pour ça qu'on l'appelle le cône rouge
même si au final
de part son ancestralité commune avec le
gène qui permet de voir le verre enfin
le gène qui code pour le cône qui permet
de voir le vert allez vous voyez que les
longueurs d'onde absorbé sont pas si
différentes mais bon ça permet une
différence significative au niveau de ce
qu'on voit donc
donc voilà les primates sont les parmi
les seuls mammifères à voir les couleurs
donc la vue est un sens très important
vision binoculaire vision des couleurs
la vue est un sens très important chez
les primates et en témoigne le fait que
les primates sont probablement les seuls
mammifères en tout cas c'est les seuls
qui me viennent à l'esprit maintenant
qu'ils qui ont la couleur bleue en fait
qu'ils ont des la peau qui peut être
bleu enfin qui peut être bleu autrement
qu'avec un hématome évidemment mais
voilà si vous regardez le mandrill si
vous regardez alors je n'ai aucune idée
de vous quel est le nom français de ces
bestioles là
mais ce sont des cercopithèque si je me
rappelle bien donc moi je les appelle
les michael jackson parce qu'ils n'ont
pas donné mais voilà année ce sont les
et puis vous avez évidemment plein de
primates qui ont les parties génitales
bleus aussi on en verra un tout à
l'heure donc les singes vers vais par
exemple donc la couleur bleue la peau
bleue c'est un caractère qu'on ne
retrouve que chez les primates et enfin
pas que chez les primates mais parmi les
mammifères on le retrouve surtout chez
les primates et c'est pas pour rien
c'est parce qu'on a une vision tri
chromate donc on est capable de mieux
distinguer justement les couleurs donc
voilà avis avis à tous les amateurs
d'avatar voilà c'est pas pour rien que
les na'vi sont bleus c'est parce qu'ils
y ont eux aussi une vision tri chromate
donc trêve de plaisanterie et de
références geek passons à la phylogénie
voilà bah tiens puisqu'on parle de bleu
les primates font partie du clad bleus
les oeufs archontes hogli donc les
orques en tongs lire qui représente la
branche arboricole enfin les les
primates font partie de la branche 2 e
art coteaux de lire qui représente la
branche arboricole donc c'est à dire les
archontes alors comment identifient
comme en identifie ton un archonte
qu'est ce qui fait que les primates sont
des arts compte donc encore une fois des
gènes des tonnes de gènes des tonnes et
des tonnes de gênes soutiennent ça mais
nous on est là pour la morphologie est
ce qu'il ya des caractères
morphologiques qui soutiennent les
archontes alors chez les archontes il ya
deux autres familles j'aurais peut-être
dû lui présenter avant il ya deux autres
familles qu'on avait rapidement
présenter quand même dans la troupe
promis la toute première leçon
ce sont les dernières terres ou call you
go ou les murs volant et les scandant
sia qu'on appelle aussi les to paille ou
musaraigne arboricole musaraigne
arboricole étant une traduction un peu
cracra 2
du nom anglais au final donc on les
appelle plutôt les to paille quoi donc
les scandant siae les dermot terrain
vous voyez un crâne ici et là alors ils
sont assez différents en soi est très
différent des primates ils n'ont pas de
vision binoculaire évidemment ils n'ont
pas de pouce opposable ils ont des
griffes mais ils ont pour eux quand même
d'avoir deux incisives supérieures donc
trois incisive inférieur mais deux
incisives supérieures c'est à dire
qu'ils sont quand même un pas plus
proche des primates que n'importe quel
autre mammifère que les incisives
inférieurs sont pros clive donc vous
pouvez voir les incisives inférieur
penchée vers l'avant et ça c'est un
caractère qui ne partagent pas avec tous
les primates mais qu'il partage quand
même avec les lémuriens les lémuriens on
les incisives proclif donc il se
pourrait qu'en fait les incisives
proclif soit un caractère partagé entre
les entre les primates bazzo que sont
les lémuriens et les autres arts compte
aussi on a une barre post orbitaire au
moins celle et scandant tia donc au
moins chez le to buy
ce qui est aussi un caractère ce qui est
un caractère partager avec les primates
vous voyez qu'il ya une belle barbe post
orbitaire chez les primates donc
adaptation à l'herbe ivory chez les
primates celle et scandant tia ça peut
pas être le cas parce qu'ils sont plutôt
si je ne m'abuse ils sont plutôt
insectivores encore que ça reste à
vérifier
ah oui et évidemment et des caractères
il ya toujours des caractères sur le
pénis parce que c'est le plus marrant
hein la classification basée sur les
parties génitales
donc la classification basée sur les
parties génitales nous dit que les
primates et les autres arts compte
partagent un pénis pendulaires c'est à
dire que le pénis pan voilà donc
généralement le si vous regardez un
chien par exemple le pénis est rétractée
à l'intérieur de l'abdomen quand il est
quand il n'est pas en érection peuvent
toucher les primates et les arcs ont et
les autres arts compte c'est pas le cas
on se secoue la nouille à l'air libre de
façon généreuse et tout à fait
sans gêne voilà et alors du coup après
un caractère comme ça je ne peux que
développer un caractère hyper technique
histoire de regagner en crédibilité
l'astragale montre les facettes sus
tentaculaire de l'astragale sont
fusionnés et en forme de l chez les
lézards compte donc voici la condition
primitive vous avez une facette sus
tentaculaire la facette sus tentaculaire
antérieures la facette sus tentaculaire
postérieur et ses deux facettes sont
complètement fusionné chez les autres
arts compte donc vous avez ici le col
hugo donc l'un des reporters vous avez
ici le tout paille
vous avez en des purgatorio purgatorio
rappelez vous c'est le plus ancien
primates connu à celui qui daterait au
moins du paléocène sinon même du crétacé
et on connaît son astra gala vous voyez
la taille de l'astragale est très petit
mais on voit quand même vous voyez la
fusion des deux facettes et qui sont en
forme de l voyez est très en forme de l
aussi chez les primates donc e et f sont
des primates et vous voyez cette forme
de l très prononcé donc la facette sus
tentaculaire si je ne m'abuse c'est
l'articulation avec le calcanéum voilà
et ça ce serait une ce serait un
caractère qui serait finalement serait
en commun enfin se développerait en
relation avec l'arbre larbaud réalité
donc la vie arboricole voilà des arts
compte d'ailleurs c'est un caractère qui
est convergent avec les chauves souris
donc d'où là d'où le fait déjà que les
chauves souris étaient considérés comme
des archontes autrefois et d'où le fait
que maintenant on pense que c'est juste
une convergence due au mode de vie
arboricole de tous ces animaux bas
encore que les chauves-souris ont un peu
laissé tomber le mode de vie arboricole
pour pas mal d'entre elles mais voilà
elle était primitivement arboricole
d'ailleurs quand vous voyez les dermot
terre c'est quand même enfin si vous
aimez vous imaginez bien que quand on a
vu que les chauves souris avec une
facette sus tentaculaire en forme de l
est qu on a vu que les dermot ptet rossi
avait ça vous imaginez
bien que ça a été que la pilule a été
dure à digérer quand on quand on s'est
mis à dire que les chauves souris
étaient plus proches des périseaux
dactyle là vous imaginez bien que ce que
ça a eu du mal à passer ça a quand même
un nom en fait vous voyez ce groupe
freire qui est qui qui plane et qui
pourrait être qu'il serait tout à fait
idéal et ben non en fait les chauves
souris elles sont plus proches des
chevaux voilà ta gueule on a presque
envie de dire ta gueule c'est génétique
finalement c'est tellement c'est
tellement c'est vrai quoi
bref alors les ancêtres possible des
primates et bien il s'agirait des
plaisirs d'api forme dont purgatorio us
donc fait partie alors ces plaisirs
d'api forme je l'aimais avec des
guillemets parce qu'en réalité c'est un
groupe extrêmement hétérogène de
archontes extrêmement hétérogène pour
pas dire poliphile éthique parce que il
y en a certains qui sont plus proches
parents des der most r&d skandia et il y
en a d'autres qui sont effectivement
proches des primates
voilà donc purgatorio ce serait le
primate le plus ancien donc avec un
registre fossile qu'il irait jusqu'au
paléocène inférieur voire au crétacé
comme je le disais bon là le crétacé
n'est pas représenté parce que à bon
évidemment c'est il ya controverse il ya
controverse donc on essaie d'être 7
phylogénie la reste prudente et il ya
plein d'autres groupes de plaisir d'api
forme qui pourrait faire partie eux
aussi du des primates ou être très
proche des primates et parmi eux parmi
eux on trouve notamment l'écart paul
east idée donc l'écart paul east idées
ils ont ils ont ceci pour eux qu'ils ont
un pouce opposable
donc vous voyez ici opposable à lux donc
c'est ce qui vous est représentée ici
vous voyez le petit pouce opposable de
ce primate alors vous voyez que les
incisives son proclif évidemment donc on
a tous les caractères qu'on retrouve
chez les autres arts compte plus le
pouce opposable est plus un ongle
uniquement sur le pouce bon alors ça
veut dire que les autres doigts ans des
griffes mais avoir un ongle sur au moins
à des doigts c'est déjà mieux que rien
c'est déjà mieux que zéro donc ça les
placerait aussi un peu plus près des
primates
et on a une bulle pète reuze chessé che
ck repos listed et au moins
partiellement pétrole c'est à dire que
le petrov et participe sans former la
totalité du tympanique de la bulletin
panique donc voilà il ya encore un
résident un reste de teint panique chez
les chez les ch et les plaisirs d'api
forme mais voilà c'est déjà là on a
quand même un bon candidat parmi ces
carpeaux listed et donc les cartes
pauliste idées sont ici et puis après
tout les autres il ya plein d'autres
groupes de plaisir d'api forme que je
vais pas détailler mais c'est plus que
c'est plus controverse il ya plus de
controverses au niveau des autres
groupes l'écart palestine et il commence
à y avoir un bon consensus autour d'eux
évidemment on a des plaisirs de alors
les plaisirs d'api forme
ce sont des ce sont des insectivores et
des frugivores comme vous comme cela est
représentée ici qui ont vécu un peu
partout en dans l'hémisphère nord
essentiellement donc on les retrouve
effectivement en amérique du nord mais
on les retrouve aussi en europe et en
asie et en france on a un très très beau
plaisir d'api forme qui est un plaisir
d'apice qui a été retrouvé dans un
cratère de un ancien cratère de volcan
de
dauvergne amenas et donc ce cratère de
ce fossile est magnifiquement préservé
on voit notamment il préserve des tissus
mous donc on voit les poils on voit le
système digestif donc si vous ne savez
pas quoi google et ce soir si vous savez
pas quoi procrastiner procrastiner
plaisir d'apice de mena on les dérives
des études récentes ont mais on dit que
c'était peut-être plus tôt mais nato
terium que plaisir d'apice mais bon
voilà il est il est aussi connu sous le
nom de plaisir d'apice je pense même que
vous aurez moins de mal à le trouver
sous le nom de plagiat d'apice mais bref
si vous trouvez pas pelé en vo tapant
plaisir la piste ap hm nato terium donc
là comme la ville de mena et avec thau
terium à la fin et alors là on attaque
le gros gros gros morceau la
classification des primates
alors ça a l'air simple comme ça ça
l'est pas du tout en réalité donc ici
vous avez un petit arbre phylogénétique
qui vous représente le les âges de
divergences en millions d'années et qui
vous représente aussi les noms des
claques donc vous avez les lémuriens
létard scier les primates du nouveau
monde les primates de l'ancien monde
parmi lesquels on compte les sages et
les grands singes et vous allez en chier
parce que évidemment c'est pas
évidemment les noms scientifiques ne
sont pas aussi simples que les noms
vernaculaires à savoir que bat tout le
groupe des lémuriformes et de leurs
proches parents ça s'appelle les strips
siréniens avec deux r s'il vous plaît et
1 h alors que le groupe des primates non
lémuriformes donc non associé au strip
siréniens ce sont les apps laurine ya
toujours avec un h mais sans le deuxième
r ensuite on allait platinien qui sont
les singes du nouveau monde avec deux r
et les catarhiniens les sages du nouveau
monde de l'ancien monde parlant avec
2,06 voilà et qui comprend donc ce qu'on
appelle communément les singes et les
les
les grands singes donc en réalité ce
qu'on appelle communément les sages
c'est l'ensemble platinien plus
catarhiniens alors il ya des grosses
différences entre le français et
l'anglais
à ce niveau là donc ce que les anglais
appellent des sages autant pour moi
c'est les plats tirrenia les
catarhiniens en français on a plutôt
tendance à appeler tous les primates des
singes y compris les lémuriens ou alors
on fait comme les anglais et ont fait
que plate a rien pas tyrrhénienne et
catarhiniens
ou alors on appelle les sages que les
que les cercopithèque au heat c'est à
dire que les sages de l'ancien monde
donc il ya plusieurs variations sur leur
usage du mot sage et honnêtement j'ai
pas la prétention de résoudre ce débat
purement étymologique maintenant fins
purement c'est purement grammaticales
quoi je m'en fiche un peu
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on utilise des
noms scientifiques d'ailleurs c'est
parce que les gens parlent de choses
différentes c'est comme le terme grands
singes l'anglais a ceci pour lui qu il
différencie les manques qui donc les
sages des ips les grands singes planet
of dit à ips
donc la planète des sages en réalité ça
devrait être la planète des grands
singes sauf que le problème c'est qu'en
anglais on allait à ips
donc les grands sages qui inclut les
gibbons et les autres grands sages donc
les orangs outans les gorilles les
chimpanzés l'homme mais ils ont aussi
grete waitz qui se traduit aussi par
grands singes et qui inclut seulement
l'orang outan le gorille le chapon les
chimpanzés et le genre le genre homo
enfin le les humains et donc ça a été ça
exclut les gibbons et donc ça aide pas
vraiment parce que évidemment le
évidemment les la traduction de fc2
great lakes c'est la même ces grands
singes quoi donc nous on n'a que ça j'ai
grands singes alors que en anglais ils
ont manqué ips et greta ips donc ça va
être un peu le bordel je vous avoue je
vous l'annonçais tout de suite et il va
falloir utiliser les noms scientifiques
parce que eux au moins ils ne varient
pas d'une langue à l'autre
voilà et c'est pour ça qu'on donne des
noms scientifiques pourri oklad c'est
parce que au moins après ils ont une
définition bien solide après voilà au
cas vous vous demandiez c'est pour ça
qu'on fait ça donc on commence avec la
division fondamentale la plus ancienne
parmi les primates celle qui a eu lieu
il ya au moins une soixantaine de
millions d'années
elle peut être plus ancienne elle peut
être plus récente évidemment il ya des
marges d'erreur autour de ça mais en
gros on est sur une division qui a
possiblement eu lieu au palais hossein
la division entre les strips si rien et
les apps l'origne donc les strips
sirénia ce sont les lémuriens et leurs
associés les loris aussi les lémuriens à
madagascar les loris sur le continent et
ce sont les primates qu'on appelle les
primates à museau humide
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont une truffe
alors là la langue française gagne parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'équivalent au mot
truffe en anglais donc quand j'essaye
d'expliquer aux étudiants que les que
les primes que les strips sirénia ont
une truffe
ils sont tous perdus parce que il croit
que je parle d'un champignon
voilà la très fun donc non non non la
truffe c'est leur hymne arrion quoi si
vous préférez pour le terme scientifique
et si vous regardez donc les apps
l'orignal eux ont un échec donc avec
deux petites narines orienté vers le bas
comme vous pouvez le voir
donc ça ce sont les apps l'orignal et
primates année sexe et nous faisons
partie donc des primates année sec alors
les strips sérignan ont d'autres
caractéristiques
ils ont notamment les incisives
inférieur qui forment un peigne dentaire
alors il n'y a que deux incisives
là vous avez une incisive et voici la
deuxième à 6 yves et là vous avez une
incisive mais elle est divisée en deux
et une autre à sisyphe donc deux
incisives mais qui sont pros clivé forme
un peigne dentaires comme chez les
hommes comme chez les autres the arts
compte donc
donc ça c'est aussi un caractère
important des strips sérignan et enfin
dernier caractère important pour
distinguer les strips sien c'est la
griffe de toilette donc la griffe de
toilettes toutes les doigts ont des
ongles chez les strips si rien sauf
l'index qui a une griffe donc l'index
même des pattes avant uniquement et
cette grippe
ils s'en servent évidemment comme pour
comme d'ailleurs le le peigne dentaire
cette griffe ils s'en servent pour se
nettoyer pour enlever les parasites
donc tout ça c'est ce sont des
caractères qui ont évolué
afin de permettre de se nettoyer donc
les apps l'origne en eux et ils sont des
gros crasseux voilà ils n'ont pas tout
ça par contre ils ont des caractères
dérivés propre évidemment et ils ont
notamment la la fermeture en fait de
l'orbité donc si vous regardez à
l'arrière de l'oeil
vous pouvez pas passer le doigt à
travers leurs beats alors que chez les
strips siréniens vous pouvez donc je
vais vous montrer un crâne de strips si
rien juste ici évidemment je n'en ai pas
je n'en ai pas mais là en fait si vous
mettez votre doigt dans l'oeil l'apsa
passe au travers et vous vous retrouvez
dans la fosse temporal en fait donc ça
ça n'arrive pas chez les simples
auriniens parce que chez les employeurs
vous avez cette muraille en fait qui
sépare la cavité du muscle temporal de
leurs beats ensuite le frontal et le
dentaire sont fusionnés enfin les
frontaux donc c'est à dire les eaux qui
sont au dessus des yeux ici et la
symphyse d'eads en d2
des deux mandibules sont fusionnés donc
ça veut dire qu'en gros il n'y a plus de
suture entre les eaux qui se trouve au
dessus des yeux ici et il ya plus de
futures entre les deux os qui forment la
mâchoire dont vous pouvez voir que cette
su que là c'est bien fusionner ses
solides
donc ça c'est aussi un caractère d'apple
auriniens et les apps l'orignal il faut
savoir que dans la littérature ils sont
très souvent appelé les singes
anthropoïdes donc les singes
anthropoïdes c'est un synonyme
finalement d'ap l'origne alors voyons
d'abord les strips syrie n'y a je vous
ai déjà ce prix laissait diapos mais
c'est pas grave
les strips si rien donc on retrouve une
certaine diversité dans cette famille
évidemment on connaît tous les murs
voilà à illac to move it c'est lui le
king julian donc
on connaît tous les lémuriens de
madagascar mais il ya aussi les indes
rider à madagascar qu'il faut pas
oublier et dobbins tonia donc le fameux
zahia qui a ni plus ni moins que le
titre de primates le plus moche du monde
c'est officiel voilà qui ressemble à un
gros gremlins mais on a pas que les
strips tianya sont pas limités quand
même
a madagascar on les retrouve aussi sur
le continent on en retrouve en afrique
et en asie comme les loris idée est
évidemment le légat lago qu'on retrouve
en afrique donc et puis voilà ils sont
tous mignons quoi elle est lors si les
loris idées ils ont aussi un autre titre
c'est celui d'être les seuls primates
venimeux donc il ya une espèce de loris
idée d'asie du sud est qui a une glande
à venin sur l'épaule et donc il lèche la
glande à venin et ce qui empoisonne leur
morsure donc les strips si rien ils ont
une histoire particulière donc de ne
serait-ce que par leur distribution vous
pouvez déjà comprendre que en gros ils
ont certainement une origine en afrique
et ensuite ils ont dérivé jusqu'à
madagascar à un moment de leur histoire
donc d'après le registre fossile il
semblerait que les primates
streep syrie n'ya est atteint madagascar
entre 60 et 50 millions d'années et
bon c'est ya rien de graver dans le
marbre parce qu'évidemment le registre
fossile de madagascar pour le scénario
hic c'est pas la fête
mais après c'est très probable qu'ils
aient atteint entre 60 et 50 millions
d'années parce que aussi c'est aussi
parce que ils sont descendants d'un
groupe qu'on appelle les adapte forme
donc les adapter forme ça viendra d'api
ce qui est ni plus ni moins que le
premier primate à avoir été découvert le
premier primate fossile qui ait jamais
été découverts étaient à d'apice
parisienne six parce qu'il a été
découvert dans à montmartre par cuvier
est donc enfin pas par cuvier il a été
découvert par les mineurs qui
travaillaient à montmartre mais décrit
par cuvier donc
et voilà on est ça nous fait remonter
sur un beau petit 19e siècle quand même
donc c'est en france qu'on a découvert
le premier primate fossile tintin tintin
tintin et cocorico et tout ça mais voilà
les adapter donc seraient les ancêtres
directs des strips siréniens on retrouve
peu ou prou les mêmes caractères chez
les a' d'happy days chez les strips
syrie n'ya donc comme je le disais la
dea d'happy days les plus connus ca
d'apice parisienne 6 mai l'adap idées
dont vous avez certainement le plus
entendu parler c'est darwinius darwinius
massillae qui remporte le
le titre de primates le plus complet
jamais découvert toutes catégories
confondues le primate fossile le plus
complet de toutes catégories confondues
le squelette tout est là je veux dire
tout le squelette est là il manquait
rien même pas une vertèbre de
l'actionnariat et on a en plus les
tissus mous d'ailleurs le fossile dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure mais nato
terium ressemble un peu disons que c'est
un peu comme d'arminius mais on n'a que
la partie supérieure par contre on n'a
pas là on n'a pas la partie inférieure
donc voila et après pour ce qui est des
ancêtres possible sur le continent
africain des lémuriens on a djebe les
murs du coup donc gb les murs qui vient
de les hauts de seine d'afrique du nord
est alors le truc c'est que tous aient à
tapis des tous ces possibles strip
sirinyan qui pourrait être ancestraux au
lémuriformes en fait ils ont pas une
fois passé le lit gaussen en gros on les
retrouve plus donc ils sont forcément
arriver à madagascar avant et c'est pour
ça qu'on pense que les murs sont arrivés
entre 60 et 50 millions d'années hills
c'est parce que voilà ils n'ont pas pu
arriver beaucoup plus tard au plus tard
il ya 30 millions d'années mais on n'a
pas après il ya aussi le fait
j'oublie évidemment l'un des caractères
important mais il ya aussi le fait qu'on
a réussi à dater l'âge de divergence des
des lémuriens de délits mais rien de
madagascar et que cet âge de divergence
grâce aux phylogénie moléculaire grâce à
l'horloge moléculaire on peut le placer
à de 60 à 50 millions d'années mais
parce qu'il ya un mais et là je veux
vous demander d'attendre la diapo
suivante parce que j'ai encore envie de
parler de ces petits animaux là donc il
y à un mais à cette histoire il y a un
gros gros mais parce que déjà là vous
commencez à sentir qu'il ya de
l'entourloupe vous sentez certainement
d'ores et déjà l'entourloupe en vous
disant attendait là on a une fenêtre on
a une fenêtre de tir qui remontent du
paléocène jusqu'à le ligue scène il est
en train de nous dire que ça s'est passé
que entre 60 et 50 millions d'années
qu'est-ce qui nous raconte il y a
effectivement guy sous roche
mais c'est la diapo suivante pour
l'instant on va s'intéresser rapidement
aussi à d'autres événements de
dispersion qui ont eu lieu entre
l'afrique est le continent on a parlé
des temps rec notamment
et alors les temps ray qui a une marge
d'erreur considérable à 2,42 à 25
millions d'années parce que rappelez
vous on retrouve des temps rec sur le
continent qui sont plus proches des
temps règles de madagascar que d autre
que d potamot galinée qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui en afrique donc encore une
fois vous vous rappelez de cette
division majeure entre potamot galinée
et en récit des bains le problème c'est
qu'on trouve des tenrécidés aussi sur le
continent'' donc ça fait un peu chier
donc voilà il ya une marge d'erreur
considérable sur la dispersion des temps
avec on retrouve les rongeurs évidemment
puisque les rongeurs en ont rien à
[ __ ] des ponts continentaux ils se
dispersent quoi qu'il arrive le rongeur
ils font ce qu'ils veulent et il ya les
carnivores et notamment les rp steed et
qui ont traversé donc au mieux aux
scènes et ont donné les faux seins donc
vous vous rappelez des harpistes idées
avec leur petit incisive leur petit
première paire d'incisives donc
maintenant les way les lémuriens de
madagascar évidemment vous vous
connaissez les lémuriens moderne mais il
n'ya pas que les lémuriens modernes y
avait une grande diversité de lémuriens
à madagascar avant l'arrivée de l'homme
l'homme qui est arrivé si je ne m'abuse
entre je crois qu'il est arrivé il ya
5000 ans mais on a retrouvé il ya pas
longtemps des restes qui pourrait
repousser le l'arrivée de l'homme encore
plus loin mais bon ça se compte en
milliers d'années à l'arrivée de l'homme
à madagascar c'est ça se compte pas en
centaines en dizaines ou en centaines de
milliers d'années ça se compte en
milliers d'années
donc il ya quelques millénaires de
slalom est arrivé et l'arrivée de
l'homme à madagascar coïncide avec
l'extinction de énormément de lémuriens
fin de primates de madagascar en général
et d'autres espèces comme le plaisir aux
recteurs opus par exemple dont on a
parlé aussi l'hippopotame nain aussi a
disparu il y avait un hippopotame nain
madagascar qui a disparu avec l'arrivée
de l'homme est donc là vous voyez mes
galas d'apice qui est donc à
lémuriformes enfin lémuriens euros qui
faisait la taille d'un gorille et il y
en avait pas qu'un là je vous montre mes
galas d'apice mais il y en avait pas car
il y avait des indes rider un driss
aussi qui faisait la taille qui faisait
dé taille considérable
donc toute cette mégafaune hélas comme
la plupart des mégaphones s'est éteinte
avec l'arrivée de l'homme et encore une
fois je parle pas de quoi je parle pas
de conquistadors je parle des gens qu'on
appelle les natifs malgache aujourd'hui
évidemment
évidemment il ya 5000 ans n'étaient pas
des conquistadors bref je m'égare un peu
donc l'histoire l'histoire des primates
donc et de leur dispersion à madagascar
elle serait très simple s'il n'y avait
pas d'eau benneteau n'y a donc là y
aille parce que l'aïe
déjà il a un profil la ja et vous voyez
qu'il a une gueule il a il a donc cette
dentition très particulière vous voyez
des molaires extrêmement simple des
prémolaires qui ont disparu donc un
diastème et des uns et des canines aussi
d'ailleurs qui ont disparu et des
incisives proclif certes mais qui ne
forment plus un pin dentaire qui
ressemble à des incisives de rongeurs
donc ça c'est parce qu'ils les utilisent
pour ouvrir finalement les les troncs
d'arbres et il utilise cette espèce de
deux griffes là que vous voyez donc il
tapote sur les troncs d'arbres pour
trouver les trous avec sa longue leaf et
puis après ils ouvrent les troncs
d'arbres avec ses dents et il fourre son
doigt pour aller à la pêche à la larve
en fait donc c'est un mode de vie
extrêmement spécialisé et donc le lay
haye le problème c'est que maïs au brand
pas du tout avec les lémuriformes sur la
phylogénie des lémuriens
il se branche il se branche à part et du
coup ça voulait dire en fin du mois si
on se contentait seulement des espèces
modernes ça voulait déjà dire qu'il
compte devrait compter deux événements
de dispersion chez les primates et ça ça
foutait un peu la merde
et oui donc un événement de dispersion
entre 50 et 60 millions d'années qui
aurait donné daube antonia et un
événement plus récent probablement mis
en scène qui aurait donné les
lémuriformes est en fait il ya pas très
longtemps je crois que c'est l'année
dernière on a découvert plaisir au pit
et cus et plaisir pittacus il a ceci
pour lui qu'il est un peu intermédiaire
entre le lémuriformes enfin le strip
sierre il ya moins de base et dobbins
antonia vous pouvez voir qu'il assez
incisive qui sont effectivement
transformé en gros incisif comme d'aubin
tonia qui forment plus le pen dentaire
mais il a encore des canines des
prémolaires et la morphologie dentaire
est encore complexe et n'est pas ultra
simplifiée comme celle de nos bateaux
n'y a donc plaidé au pit et cus ses
attraits une très très belle espèce
intermédiaire entre micro ces bus et
d'obtenir enfin entre le lémurien de
base et le strip sirinyan base et
dobbins antonia oui mais plusieurs
pittacus il a été découvert en egypte
dans le lit gaussen d'égypte et il ya
encore d'autres espèces un peu moins
bien connues comme propre auto mais en
tout cas quoi qu'il arrive
eh ben on est on est sur une origine
continental d
de la famille de daube antonia donc les
kiri leckie romy forme voilà et donc ça
ça veut dire qu'en gros d'aubaine tonia
baïla il s'est dispersé à madagascar que
relativement tard et alors peut-être que
du coup il n'est pas impossible comme
cela rapproche considérablement
l'origine de daube antonia de celle des
autres lémuriformes malgache donc en
bleu ciel vous avez les espèces malgache
en rouge vous avez les espèces
africaines
eh bien eh bien peut-être qu'on n'efface
qu'à un seul événement de dispersion qui
n'auraient pas eu lieu donc il ya entre
60 et 50 millions d'années mais plutôt
en même temps que les autres quads
c'est-à-dire au mis en scène ce que vous
voyez que les autres ils ont un
événement de dispersion qui est plutôt
mis en scène donc peut-être qu'on en
saurait sur un seul gros événement de
dispersion qui aurait eu lieu au milieu
scène et qui aura à mener toutes les
espèces d'un coup bon pourquoi pas alors
on a vu les strips si rien maintenant on
monte au monde dans l'arbre comme tel
les primates et on arrive 58 millions
d'années avec la division entre les
tares six formes et les autres primates
donc on est on entre chez les apps
l'orignal donc les apps l'orignal je
vous le rappelle ce sont ceux qui ont
les orbites qui sont complètement fermés
et le nez sec et donc la pl auriniens le
plus banal et bien c'est tarsus le
tarsier et vous pouvez voir que le
tarsier il a un obstiné sait qu'à tout
ce qui a de plus appelé auriniens ou
anthropoïdes
encore une fois je le rappelle que a
plus rien et anthropoïdes sont synonymes
et on vous pouvez voir que le tarsier en
fait il est pareil on est on est face à
une espèce qui a des caractères
intermédiaire parce que le tarsier il a
les orbites qui sont à moitié fermés en
fait vous voyez le mur orbitaire le mur
post orbitaire en fait n'est pas
complètement fermée il est fermé sur le
dessus mais il est encore ouvert sur le
dessous ce qui est intermédiaire entre
le mur complètement fermé des apps lors
il n'ya plus dérivés et l'absence totale
de mur à l'arrière de des lémurs de
l'orbiel des lémuriens donc là vous
pouvez voir que ça passe au travers
complètement si vous pouvez mettre votre
doigt au travers alors que là ça passe
plus et ben là ça parce qu'à moitié ça
passera que si vous avez un petit doigt
voilà ça c'est de la définition n'est ce
pas donc l'état si aujourd'hui on les
retrouve plus qu'en en asie du sud est
ils sont bien reconnaissables à leurs
yeux gigantesque alors je sais que les
jeux c'est que internet les mêmes
d'internet ont tendance à appeler les
tarsier des lémuriens voilà vous avez le
fameux même du lait du lémurien qui
ouvre grand les yeux et bien c'est parce
que les gens confondent les tares ci
avec les loris regarder les loris sont
là voyez le loris a aussi de très grands
yeux mais il n'a pas d'oreille
mais alors que le quartier lui ressemble
plus à un gremlin loyer il a des yeux il
ya des belles oreilles
voilà donc c'est comme ça et évidemment
il a un échec
contrairement aux loris le l'orissa une
truffe donc voilà on arrête de confondre
maintenant les tares scié et les loris
s'il vous plaît et alors chez le
quartier on a aussi d'autres caractère
primitif c'est à dire le frontal et l'as
un fils dentaire qui ne sont pas encore
fusionné alors pour voir le frontal sur
cette photo c'est pas évident mais par
contre vous pouvez voir la suture qui
est encore visible sur la service
dentaire alors qu'elle ne l'est plus
chez le babouin
voilà donc le tarse y est c'est fait
donc les quartiers on a bon le registre
fossile des tares sied-il est pas il
n'est pas grandiloquent on a
possiblement
un fossile qui s'appelle archi ces bus
et qui vient de l'éocène d'asie et qui
alors qu'ils aient de l'éocène inférieur
donc ce serait un des plus anciens a
plus rien si on ne compte pas l'espèce
dont je vais parler un peu plus tard qui
s'appelle halte i hate l'asus donc mais
maintenant on monte un peu plus haut
donc on arrive au a plus rien donc avec
une origine qui aurait environ 40
millions d'années mais encore une fois
c'est si on néglige haïti est la zus
mais on va parler d'haïti at l'asus en
temps et en heure ne vous en faites pas
mais voilà on serait sur une origine
d'environ 40 millions d'années donc on
est à l'eocène moyen supérieur quoi
voilà si on compte la marge d'erreur ça
fait hossein moyen supérieur donc les
apps l'orignal les vrais ceux qui n'ont
pas les arbitres à moitié fermés ceux
qui ont leurs beats complètement
complètement fermée donc chez les apps
l'orignal vous avez encore une fois une
division fondamentale celle entre les
sages du nouveau monde les plati rien et
celle entre les siens sage de l'ancien
monde les catarhiniens donc les apps
l'orignal les catarhiniens comment les
différents sites on est bien on va
regarder encore une fois les dents les
platinien donc les singes du nouveau
monde ont une deux trois mots l'air et
une de 3 prémolaires alors que les
catarhiniens ils ont une deux trois mots
l'air et seulement une de molaire voilà
donc si vous comptez votre nombre de
molaire vous constaterez que vous en
avez 3 et que vous avez deux prémolaires
en avant de ces de ces primes de ses
molaires et ensuite vous passez
directement à la canine et bien ça ça
fait de vous un qatari n'ya vous êtes un
catarhiniens félicitations donc un singe
de l'ancien monde
ce qui est totalement logique puisqu'on
a évolué en afrique donc voila tout va
bien et après vous avez d'autres
caractères d'autres caractères qui
caractérise les aplombs rien enfin les
platinien des catarhiniens donc ces
caractères ce sont d'une part au niveau
de la bulle donc bull qui est formé par
le pétrole je rappelle la bulle petrosa
halle où pète reuze et bien les
platinien ont en fait non pas de tubes à
la sortie de cette bulle
donc ils ont directement un trou qui
donne dans la bulle donc
vous avez la bulle ici vous avez le trou
easy directement alors que chez les
cathares et alors que chez les
catarhiniens la bulle est placé un peu
plus vers l'intérieur du crâne donc un
peu plus médias allemands c'est ce que
vous voyez ici ça c'est la bulle et du
coup pour atteindre le bord du crâne
eh bien il vous faut un tube et ce tube
est aussi fier chez les catarhiniens
donc vous avez la bulle avec un tube qui
conduit jusqu'à l'extérieur et ça c'est
typique des catarhiniens enfin un
caractère qui est un peu plus balèze a
observé parce que il est pas enfin je
veux dire il faut vraiment avoir accès
au futur du crâne mais si vous regardez
un crâne de platinien vous verrez que
l'os pariétal sépare complètement le
frontal du square mozart donc le square
aux halles c'est celui qui forment la
base de l'arcade zygomatique
à l'arrière le frontal c'est ce fameux
os dont on ne voit plus la suture mais
au milieu c'est l'os qui se trouve au
dessus des yeux est en fait le frontal
et le squames aux halles sont
complètement séparés par le pariétal
donc c'est à dire l'os qui forment le
gros de la boîte crânienne alors que
chez les catarhiniens le pariétal et
rétracter vers l'arrière et du coup vous
avez une suture entre le frontal et le
square mozart ou entre le frontal et le
ce fait nos idées donc le spin ritz et
c'est un autre os qui participent à la
boîte crânienne
mais voilà le pari étals et poussé vers
l'arrière par le frontal voilà si vous
voilà si vous voulez retenir qu'une
chose c'est que le pariétal et plus
court latéralement chez les catarhiniens
que chez les platines
voilà et donc donc avec tous ces
caractères ça permet d'avoir une bonne
idée de quand de quand datent les plates
l'ancêtre commun des platinien des
qatari n'y a pas ce qu on a un très bon
registre fossile de ces deux groupes
qui commence dès le lit gaussen en fait
avec parra pittacus pour les zap
l'origne pour les plates irinia et
egypte au pit et cus pour les
catarhiniens j'en profite aussi de pour
vous montrer cette image la boîte
crânienne
on en a pas trop parlé sur cette diapos
là mais voilà les tarsier ont un cerveau
qui est globalement comparable à celui
des lémuriens là vous voyez qu avec les
apps laurie n'ya plus dérivés les
platines et à les catarhiniens on
commence à taper dans du cerveau qui est
bien bien développé un
bon la lâcher les tarsier l'oeil est
littéralement plus gros que le cerveau
bon ça ça va aussi de pair avec le fait
que les tarsier sont nocturnes et que
comme les primates non pas de taper tom
lucide sommes donc l'absence de [ __ ]
sommes lucides sommes chez les primates
c'est c'est quelque chose que vous
connaissiez peut-être en gros les
primates n'ont pas cette espèce de
couches de cellules qui reflètent la
lumière à l'intérieur de l'oeil
donc quand vous et quand vous avez vos
phares qui pointent vers un chat ouvert
un lapin par exemple ouvert un chien
vous voyez leurs yeux brillaient dans le
noir les phares de votre voiture voilà
donc si vous vous croisez un chien lapin
renard un chat n'importe quel animal
vous pouvez voir les yeux qui se reflète
enfin de vous pouvez voir oui la lumière
qui de vos phares qui se reflète dans
leurs yeux ça c'est parce qu'ils ont un
tape et sommes lucides hommes ils ont
une couche de mire une couche de
cellules miroir dans l'oeil tarsus n'a
pas de taper comme lui c'est d'homme
comme la plupart des primates en fait
donc
rappelez vous que les primates sont
principalement des urnes et donc ont
perdu cette capacité de réflexion de la
lumière qui puisque le tap et sommes
lucides homme sert à refléter la lumière
et donc à capter plus de lumière chez
les espèces nocturnes donc le tap et
sommes lucides homme est absent chez la
plupart des primates mais on a des
exceptions notamment parmi les les
strips sirinyan donc il ya pas mal de
strips sérignan nocturne qui on a tapé
tome du sydom donc est par contre le tap
et sommes lucides homme est absent chez
le to buy
donc c'est pas encore tout à fait clair
si si c'est une scie napo mort fissiles
la perte du tap et sommes lucides homme
est une scie napo morphy des primates ou
des archontes ou n'est pas une sinon une
synapse murphy du tout ou si c'est une
synap au mort fidea floridien en général
mais voilà le c'est pour ça que le
tarsier à d'aussi grands dieux c'est
parce qu'il est nocturne mais qu'il n'a
pas de taper sommes lucides
voilà donc cette division entre plates
irinia et catarhiniens donc entre les
sages du nouveau monde et les sages de
l'ancien monde nous amène du coup à
discuter de la diversité des sages du
nouveau monde
avant de s'attaquer aux singes de
l'ancien monde donc c'est sage du
nouveau monde
eh bien on compte parmi eux donc les
les parmi les plus connus donc les
capucins les tamarins les marmousets les
singes hurleurs sont aussi des primates
du nouveau monde
alors si vous cherchez à identifier un
primate du nouveau monde mais que vous
n'avez pas accès à son crâne vous pouvez
toujours regarder ses narines
les sages du nouveau monde ont
généralement les narines très fortement
et se passer et oriente et non pas vers
le bas mais vers le côté voir vers
l'avant donc c'est quelque chose que
vous pouvez voir très bien chez le
tamarin très bien chez le capucin un
petit peu moins chez les singes hurleurs
mais voilà ça se voit très bien aussi
chez le singe écureuils le squeeze
roulement qui je ne sais pas ce que
c'est le nom de cette petite bête on en
français est alors une d une des choses
qui me semblent intéressantes de
discuter c'est l'arrivée finalement des
plates irinia au nouveau monde justement
parce que encore une fois comme pour les
rongeurs les premiers fossiles de
platinien ils datent d'entre eux 40 et
30 millions d'années les datations sont
pas super super je vais pas dire solide
parce que bon voilà c'est pas gentil
mais voilà les datations sont pas encore
claires clair mais voilà entre 40 et
entre 30 et 40 millions d'années
on a des primates qui apparaissent très
soudainement en amérique du sud sans
aucun ancêtres possible sur place
et ça encore une fois ça pose plein de
questions et notamment celle de
l'origine de ces singes alors que de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique encore une
fois on a des on a des catarhiniens mais
on a aussi des plates iranien voilà donc
pas rapid et qu il ferait partie des
plates iranien en témoigne le nombre de
ses dents et on sait que les que les zap
l'origne un de manière générale donc les
anthropoïdes sont là depuis longtemps
d'une part parce qu'on allait tarsier
qui sont en asie donc voilà les
l'origine des des apps l'origne en
général se place dans l'ancien monde
donc les tarsier avec
avec les dom le tard s'ils forment le
plus banal archi ces bus qui se trouve
en asie et on a alti at l'asus du
paléocène du maroc dont khalti at laz
husky et n'est connu que par quelques
dents mais ses dents sont extrêmement
bruno dhont et ça c'est un caractère
qu'on retrouve chez les apps l'origne 1
les primates
ap lors il ya sont ceux qui ont les
dents les plus bruno dhont et le l'homme
l'homme moderne a hérité de cette
extrême d'une aussi qu'on retrouve déjà
chez altis d'asus et si haïti a très
hâte les yeux c'est bien à 9,1 à pleaux
rien du paléocène moi ça fait remonter
très très loin l'origine des apps
l'origne un bien plus loin que ce que
prédit d'ailleurs les plus que prédisent
les phylogénie moléculaire et l'horloge
moléculaire qui va avec
donc pour une fois ce serait les
fossiles qui donnerait un âge plus
ancien que l'horloge moléculaire ce
serait marrant mais voilà donc avec un
aplomb rien du paléocène avec impossible
à pleaux rien du paléocène d aplomb rien
confirmé en asie donc avec archi ces bus
et les tares six formes et avec des
catarhiniens et des plates à rien dans
le lit gaussen d'égypte ben quand on se
retrouve avec des plates iranien dans
les hauts-seine supérieur slash
oligocène d'amérique du sud et banias
ça laisse pas beaucoup de choix sur
l'origine des possibles des possibles
plate erignac on retrouve la cua
surtout sachant et dernière donnée
intéressante c'est que ici 7
cette carte vous représente la totalité
du registre fossile des apps l'orignal
du paléogène donc vous pouvez voir qu'en
amérique du nord il n'ya pas un seul
point donc il ya aucun naples auriniens
dans le paléogène d'amérique du nord ni
dans le néo gêne d'ailleurs les seuls à
pleaux rignac y ont jamais foulé le sol
d'amérique du nord ce sont les humains
et c'est tout les seul primate qui a
jamais eu en amérique du nord ce sont
les adapter les adapter et d'autres
familles d'autres famille de primates
aux affinités un peu plus obscurs
certaines pouvant être un peu plus un
peu plus enfin rapprocher de ddd a plus
rien
mais voilà il ya que des familles
extrêmement basale qui ont vécu en
amérique du nord même si certaines
peuvent être rapprochés des apps
l'orignal il y en a aucune qui est
autant un aplomb rien que l'egypte au
pit et cus ou par api tqs par exemple
donc il ya que des familles extrêmement
basale de primates et les plaisirs d'api
forme qui ont vécu en amérique du nord
après les après on a possiblement voilà
ce dans les groupes si vous voulez tout
savoir dans les groupes qu'on peut
retrouver en amérique du nord il ya les
homos me forme par exemple qui pourrait
être associé aux a plus rien mais rien
rien qui ressemble de près ou de loin à
ce qu'on trouve en amérique du sud en
fait c'est sale c'est surtout ça c'est
que c'est les apps l'origne impossible
qu'on retrouve en amérique du nord ne
ressemble pas du tout aux apps lorignac
on trouve en amérique du sud
les apps lorignac on retrouve en
amérique du sud il ressemble à pas
rapides et cus et aux autres platinien
qu'on trouve dans le lit gaussen de
d'égypte notamment dans encore une fois
c'est des gisements du fayoum là qui
nous ont donné du très très beau
matériel donc eh ben on est encore sur
le même scénario qu'avec les rongeurs
voilà il ya entre 30 et 40 millions
d'années
eh bien il ya un radeau flottant qui a
quitté l'afrique probablement une énorme
un énorme morceau de mangrove envoyé
dans l'océan est poussé par les alizés
direction l'amérique du sud qui je le
rappelle était 1000 km plus proche des
côtes africaines qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui et donc ils ont en effet
comme les rongeurs au final etc il est
même pas complètement improbable que ce
soit le même radeau qui est amené les
rongeurs ou du moins la même série de
deux crus qu'ils aient pu ramener les
primates en même temps que les rongeurs
au final donc maintenant on va
s'intéresser aux primates de l'ancien
monde les primates de l'ancien monde
alors ils sont divisés en deux groupes
je crois que j'ai une fille lola finaux
génie vient juste après voilà donc les
primates de l'ancien groupe de l'ancien
monde ils sont divisés en deux groupes
donc on est parmi les catarhiniens donc
un groupe dont l'âge de divergence se
trouve à 25 millions d'années donc à 25
millions d'années donc au début fin
oligocène début miocène vous avez cette
division fondamentale entre les grands
sages de ce côté ci et l'autre groupe
qu'on appelle les cercopithèque aux ide
alors les cercopithèque aux ide ou sage
du singe de l'ancien monde au sens
strict on va dire c'est cercopithèque
aux idées bien c'est c'est vraiment le
coeur delà de la diversité des primates
sur l'ancien monde et même tout court
j'ai envie de dire parce que de laisser
recopie tecau id à eux seuls ils
représentent plus de 120 espèces donc
120 espèces sur les 300 de primates
je crois que c'est 330 espèces de
primates c'est presque la moitié en fait
donc un seul groupe représente presque
la moitié de la diversité des primates
donc vous avez les macaques les
cercopithèque et les babouins les
les singes verve et les mandrills donc
tout ça c'est du cercopithèque les
cercopithèque c'est un gros bac on
retrouve sous la plus grande diversité
de l'attitude donc comme je vous ai dit
les fameux mas ka klé voilà les fameux
macaques à face rouge d'ailleurs ceux
qui sont adaptés au froid
vous avez des macaques qui vivent jusque
sur gibraltar donc techniquement c'est
l'europe
voilà c'est le seul primate européen en
a par l'homme en tout cas moderne et
puis vous avez évidemment toute cette
formidable diversité de singe un peu
partout donc voila et alors tout laisser
recopier coheed se distingue des grands
singes par déjà la présence d'une que
que les grands singes n'ont pas et par
des dents lofo doute
donc voilà la seule extravagance
dentaire que vous verrez chez les chez
les primates sellal aux faux dont 6
décès recopie tecau et donc les
cercopithèque aux ide sont fortement
adapté à un mode de un régime
alimentaire herbivores donc
principalement follivores ils ont d
adaptation du système digestif que les
que les autres primates non pas et donc
ça c'est ça fait 2-1 groupe traiteraient
avec un grand succès évolutif
voilà donc autrefois si vous remontiez
au mieux au début du miocène voire même
au milieu du miocène vous verriez un
monde qui serait dominée par les grands
singes mais les cercopithèque aux ide
larron complètement mis la pâtée à la
fin du miocène et au début du pliocène
donc ses potes ça a peut être à voir
avec l'assèchement de la méditerranée
d'ailleurs l'assèchement de la
méditerranée qui a changé le climat en
europe et en afrique où justement les
grands singes étaient très nombreux on
verra la dispersion la diversité des
grands singes dans des dents quelques
diapos donc les grands singes étaient
très nombreux en asie et en afrique
et puis bah ils se sont la crise
messinienne donc l'assèchement de la
méditerranée est passée par là et les
cercopithèque aux idioties sont passés
par là donc voilà les cercopithèque aux
ide
retenez surtout voilà c'est l'eau chaude
aussi
très typique des serres copie tecau ide
et à côté de ça et bien on a les grands
singes donc les grands sages qui eux ont
des dents bras qui bruno dhont vous
pouvez voir très fortement bras qui donc
pour certaines espèces et ils sont
caractérisés par le fait qu'ils n'ont
pas de queue et aujourd'hui ils refont
une diversité qui est extrêmement
appauvri donc voilà une chose à retenir
quand on éteint quand on est anglophone
c'est que ips et monkey c'est pas la
même chose parce que évidemment quand on
dit l'homme descend du singe en anglais
les gens disent les mânes et ceux des
sans diplômes en guise et non blancs la
vérité c'est que les hommes sont des
high plombe déjà si tu veux corriger un
petit peu ta phrase tu peux dire manihi
ce dès samedi
ex et ne dites pas qu'on a un ancêtre
commun avec les ips
ce n'est pas vrai on n'a pas d'ancêtres
en commun avec les isles ont fait partie
des ips donc on est techniquement
descendre techniquement on descend bel
et bien d'un grand singe du moins on
descend d'une espèce qui appartenait à
léo grands singes donc on descend bel et
bien d'un grand singe dire qu'on a un
ancêtre commun avec les grands singes ça
voudrait dire si on reprend la
phylogénie je crois que j'ai la
phylogénie ici voilà donc ici vous voyez
ça c'est transmettre commun c'était un
grand sage ça c'était un grand sage ça
c'est un grand sage ça s'est tellement
sage donc on est descendu d'un grand
singe dire que on est con à un ancêtre
avec les grands sages ça voudrait dire
que l'homme se branchent ici voilà un
ancêtre commun avec les grands singes ça
voudrait dire que l'homme se branchent
ici or c'est pas vrai le chimpanzé est
plus un être humain que que le
en fait le chimpanzé ressemble plus à
l'être humain qu'il ne ressemble au
gorille ou au gibbons génétiquement et
morphologiquement on va voir les
caractères morphologiques donc fait très
attention quand vous voulez contredire
quelqu'un qui vient de vous dire que
l'homme descend du singe
bon déjà l'homme descend du singe il
s'agit d'une traduction d'une expression
anglaise man in dessin manille se
dessine dit from its et non pas floues
monkeys mais surtout mais surtout quand
on dit l'homme descend du singe il faut
faire très attention à quand on veut
contredire quelqu'un qui vous dit
l'homme descend du singe il faut faire
très attention au vocabulaire qu'on
utilise l'homme et le chimpanzé partagea
d'ancêtre commun c'est la seule bonne
réponse que vous pouvez balancer
voilà où l'homme et le chimpanzé
descendre d'un même singes et l'appareil
vous êtes juste mais wef est fait très
attention à ce que vous dites quand vous
voulez contredire les gens qui vous
disent est l'une des 110 ans
voilà c'est juste ça là les mots sont
importants
les définitions sont importantes les
définitions sont même plus importante
que les mots en réalité tant qu'on sait
de quoi on parle c'est à dire que tant
que les définitions sont claires on peut
même utiliser des mots kaka voilà mais
je digresse jeudi gras ça m'arrive
souvent quand je fais court nous
atteignons donc les grands singes donc
ce qu'on appelle les hominoïdes voilà
donc les grands singes les hominoïdes
gates en anglais donc les hominoïdes se
caractérise comme je les dis par
l'extrême d'une eau dont six de leurs
dents
donc extrême but oddo cie et extrême
bracchi dont 6 aussi de leurs dents très
souvent les dents ont une émail assez
épaisse justement pour compenser le fait
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de qu'elles
sont pas très haute en fait donc l'émail
est très épaisse pour être plus
résistante et évidemment ce qui va
caractériser les hominoïdes c'est
l'absence de que donc la présence d'un
coccyx est la première espèce chez qui
on retrouve un coccyx c'est enfin les
premiers le premier groupe chez lesquels
on retrouve un coccyx ce sont les
proconsuls idée donc ici vous voyez là
squelette de et kambo alors évidemment
celui là n'a pas le coccyx mai et campos
et un proconsul idée autrefois on
l'appelait proconsul voilà mais le nom a
changé mais du coup et kambo il avait
déjà à coccyx et ils vivaient au milieu
seine inférieure donc il y à une
vingtaine de millions d'années c'est le
l'origine des grands sages donc c'est ce
qui vous ai indiqué ici voilà 18
millions d'années donc les premiers
hominoïdes apparaissent au miocène
inférieur et ils ont toute une série de
caractères l'absence de que l'extrême
bilodeau ci est l'adaptation al abrach
iations donc si vous êtes capable de
lever votre bras au dessus de votre tête
c'est que vous êtes un nominaux id tous
les sages ne savent pas faire ça en
réalité et c'est dû au fait que vous
avez une omoplate qui est allongé en
terro postérieurement et non pas
medio latéralement donc votre omoplates
en fait est plus longue que large et ça
ça vous permet c'est ça va de pair avec
une articulation particulière de la de
l'humérus avec avec justement l'omoplate
mais aussi avec une participation de la
clavicule
bref tout ça pour dire que voilà si vous
êtes capable de lever votre bras au
dessus de votre tête c'est parce que
vous avez une omoplate qui est plus
longue que large alors que les autres
singes ont des omoplates qui sont plus
larges que l'ong
donc ça ça fait aussi partie des
caractères que vous pouvez utiliser pour
vous perdre pour identifier des grands
singes et aussi les grands sages des
hominoïdes ont généralement une
troisième molaire supérieures et
inférieures qui sort de la mâchoire en
retard on va dire donc qu' une éruption
de la dent de sagesse parce que
finalement c'est ça une éruption de la
dent de sagesse qui est retardé donc ça
se voit très bien sur ce fossile en fait
vous pouvez voir que là vous avez la
première molaire la deuxième molaires et
la dent de sagesse qui est ici est donc
la deuxième molaires et très usées alors
que la dent de sagesse vous voyez encore
tous ses reliefs parfaitement préservée
donc ça ça veut dire que la dent de
sagesse était tout juste en train de
sortir quand la deuxième molaires était
déjà très usés en fait et vous pouvez
voir elle est tellement usé la première
et la deuxième molaires sont déjà
tellement usé qu'on peut qu on arrive
déjà à voir la dentine alors que la
preuve alors que la troisième molaire
n'a même pas encore été attaquées et
tout ça ça va en fait avec ce qu'on
appelle un
un trade histoires de vie lent ce qui
signifie en gros que vous avez une
gestation extrêmement allongé voilà donc
c'est nous même ne sommes adultes que
très tard dans notre vie après 18 ou 20
ans on atteint la maturité sexuelle
après seulement
après seulement la puberté donc après 10
12 ans est ce enfin il ya encore ces 10
12 ans parce qu'on est très bien nourrie
parce que c'est parce que si vous
remontez au xviiie siècle la maturité
sexuelle c'était à 17 ans c'était 17 18
ans donc voilà et le et puis si vous
regardez par exemple et les orangs
outans c'est pareil la maturité sexuelle
de l'animal c'est après neuf ans je
crois donc en tout cas le petit vie avec
la mer et aux dépens de la mer jusqu'à 9
ans ça se trouve c'est même pas encore
la maturité sexuelle donc voilà donc
l'éruption derrière finalement cette
éruption dentaire retardé il y a des
traits d'histoires de vie très lent et
donc notamment la maturité retardée
alors pour pour étendre un peu sur le
ces caractères de la braquer à sion en
fait on pense que l'ancêtre commun de
tous les hominoïdes était était en fait
finalement avait une locomotion à ses
proches de l'orang outan c'est à dire
qu'ils étaient capables de se suspendre
avec les bras comme l'orang outan ou le
gibbon il était capable de suspendre
avec les bras voire possiblement de se
déplacer de façon bipèdes dans les
arbres en tenant les branches du dessus
et en marchant sur les branches du tout
ce que fait laurent autant d'ailleurs
donc
au mans on a plusieurs scénarios qui
s'approche comme ça et donc qui ce qui
se concurrencent on va dire mais disons
que ça c'est celui qui a l'air le plus
consensuel et donc à partir de cette de
ce mode de vie arboricole possiblement
bipèdes arboricole en tout cas bras
création ça c'est sûr eh bien on a les
différentes lignes et de grands sages
qui vont évoluer l'orang outan va rester
brac yater et bipèdes arboricole les
gibbons aussi mais les gorilles les
chimpanzés les hommes en fait ils vont
devenir terrestre
donc il va y avoir une augmentation de
la taille du corps enfin ils vont
devenir un peu plus terrestres voire
complètement terrestre il va y avoir une
augmentation de la taille du corps en
fait qu'il va aller de pair avec le fait
qu'on peut plus vraiment se trimballer
dans les arbres et donc les gorille vont
évoluer ce qu'on appelle le ne recueille
walking donc le ils vont marcher en fait
sur leurs phalanges donc les gorilles
marche sur les deuxième phalange donc un
peu comme tarzan dans dans le dessin
animé les chimpanzés eux ils marchent
sur la première phalange donc c'est ce
que vous voyez là et les hominidés bas
et eux ils vont marcher sur leurs pieds
voilà donc mais tout ça ça va de pair
avec une augmentation de la taille du
corps qui empêche finalement de
continuer à se promener librement dans
les arbres bien que tous les grands
sages y compris les hominidés bazot les
hominidés bazzo vont avoir une certaine
une certaine forme d'arbre e-coli dans
l'eure dans leurs traits d'histoires de
vie on va leur quasi certaine forme
d'arbre e-coli dans leur répertoire
locomoteur devrait-on dire voilà un
autre caractère un peu marrant d des
hominoïdes c'est la perte du bas qu
l'homme donc le bas qu l'homme je
rappelle c'est l'os peña los du pénis et
donc chez les
et bien si vous si vous regardez un
babouin ils ont anos pénien bien
développée si vous regardez les strips
syrie n'ya donc comme ce strip siréniens
de l'éocène d'allemagne il y a aussi un
aspect n'yat il s'agit de europe aux
lémurs de l'éocène du message de mes
seuls en allemagne mais quand vous
regardez l'évolution du bas qu l'homme
chez les hominoïdes eh bien on part de
l'orang outan qui n'a invaincu l'homme
que de 13 mm donc déjà c'est pas des
masses et donc ce bac eu l'homme va ne
va faire que des croître en taille chez
les ch et les hominoïdes jusque chez
l'humain qui aura complètement perdu le
bas culotte et enfin un dernier petit
caractère c'est un caractère dentaire
puisque encore une fois on parle d enfin
on parle des mammifères et les
mammifères c'est surtout des dents 1
et donc si vous trouvez des dents
isolées comment faites vous pour savoir
s'il s'agit d'un homicide ou pas et bien
c'est très simple il suffit de trouver
la crise tao bly quoi donc la crise n'a
oublié quoi sur les dents supérieures
c'est une crête qui s'étend du protocole
jusqu'au met à cosne et qui est unique
aux hominoïdes donc c'est ça donc là
vous avez là dedans de base d'un primate
est ici vous avez la fameuse christa
oblique oies du protocole home et à
cosne elle est très bien il est très
visible ici et cette crise n'a oublié
quoi elle va se faire occlusion avec une
crête qui se trouve entre l'ipo connu
leed est dipoko need entre l'anp tokony
de pardon et l'ipo connu lead d
des dents inférieur donc cette crête 6
et du coup juste à côté il va y avoir
une fausse et cette fausse c'est ce
qu'on appelle le le wpt five pattern
donc le patron y 5
alors pourquoi 5 c'est probablement
parce qu'il ya 5 q speed est évidemment
pourquoi y bat parce que cette fosse est
très fortement en forme de y
donc voilà ce patron en forme de y est
le résultat de l'évolution de la crise
taoub l'icwa sur le dessus et ça c'est
très très typique des hominidés
hominoïdes donc maintenant vous pouvez
dire que vous savez exactement comment
identifier à nos minots id rien qu'avec
les dents de rien et donc grâce quand on
est armé avec tous ces caractères et
bien on est capable d'identifier
beaucoup beaucoup domino id notamment
parce que les hominoïdes était très
diversifié autant en afrique qu'en
europe camps nazis
d'ailleurs la dispa la diversité domino
id
aujourd'hui donc des grands singes
d'aujourd'hui reflète cet ancien
distribution c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on a des grands sages les
gibbons et les orangs outans en asie et
des grands singes en afrique c'est parce
que autrefois il y avait une une grande
dispersion au mit en scène notamment à
l'époque où il y avait des jungles un
peu plus partout dans le monde
eh bien on avait des hominoïdes partout
et c'est après quand ces jungles se sont
réduites donc temps mais en afrique et
en asie du sud-est que la séparation a
été consommée entre les entre les la
branche des orangs outans et des gibbons
est la branche africaine cua
enfin les branches qui conduisent aux
orangs outans et au gibbons devrais je
dire donc voila un petit juste une
petite
petit diapos qui vous montre un peu la
diversité de ses de ces primates
notamment omis hossein donc miocène
inférieur et moyens nyanza pittacus
afrobeat et qu on reconnaît bien les
grosses molaires bien carré ça aussi
c'est un caractère visible sur les
molaires si vous comparez rapidement
avec les cercopithèque au heat vous
voyez que les molaires sont plutôt
rectangulaire alors que si vous regardez
voilà les mots l'air d'un d'un
hominoïdes elles sont plutôt carré donc
ça aussi c'est un caractère utilisable
pour identifier un primates hominoïdes
donc ces grosses molaires carré qu'on
voit très bien
et ici vous avez alors le seul primate
d'afrique du sud
enfin le seul le seul hominoïdes
d'afrique du sud aussi bien fossiles que
moderne si on exclut l'homme encore une
fois et c'est alors c'est juste la
moitié d'une dent oui metz et c'est là
que ça vous montre la puissance des
caractères que je vous ai montré vous
avez le protocole une crête qui va
jusqu'aux meta caunes il y à une crise
n'a oublié quoi donc c'est bien un
primates hominoïdes donc même si on
n'ira pas jusqu'à créer une nouvelle
espèce juste pour cette dans la on peut
quand même voir qu'il s'agit d'anne
hominoïdes rien qu'en voyant qu'il y à
une crise n'a oublié et on passe
maintenant aux hominoïdes moderne donc
on a fait le tour des hominoïdes
fossiles maintenant les hominoïdes
moderne
alors je vous ai mis une petite
classification l' histoire qu'on s'y
retrouve pas ce que ça va être compliqué
vous allez voir parce que tous les os
mineur enfin entre les hominoïdes les
hominidés les hominidés les au mini
d'aller voir on va en chier
donc voilà les hominoïdes ce sont donc
les grands singes donc tous les grands
singes avec inclut les îlots baptisé
c'est à dire les gibbons
donc les îlots bâti dès qu'on appelle
aussi les soeurs eipc en anglais donc
les moindres singes je sais pas ils ont
des drôle de façon de parler les anglais
mais voilà les gibbons font partie des
hominoïdes et donc on oppose des îlots
baptisé aux hominidés groupe dans lequel
on va mettre tous les autres grands
sages de l'orang outan à l'être humain
en passant par le gorille le chimpanzé à
l'intérieur des hominidés on va avoir
les homininés qu'on oppose au pont gines
et donc la sous-famille du de l'orang
outan donc la sous-famille des homininés
contient l'homme
le chimpanzé et le gorille à l'intérieur
desquels on va trouver les soussous
famille
si je sais pas exactement où les je ne
sais pas exactement quel terme on peut
employer mais enfin ce sont des classes
de toute façon donc les souks laddh
si vous préférez des gorini des paninis
et des homininés alors je crois qu'on
dit tribut si je me rappelle bien mais
bon je viens pas vraiment d'importance
le nom qu'on donne tout ça l'important
c'est de savoir dans quel ordre on les
place voilà et d'être cohérent avec sa
surtout parce que c'est plus ça le
problème c'est d'arriver à être cohérent
parce que entre les gens qui vous disent
que les homininés donc sondé enfin sens
entre les gens qui vous parle de la
lignée humaine en disant homininés c'est
à dire ce que je fais d'ailleurs au
passage je devrais dire aux mines nine
normalement mais aux minimes ça fait
tellement anglais en fait donc moi quand
je dis homininés en fait je vais faire
les soldes je parle des aux mini jeux
d'ailleurs je parle jamais des homininés
en réalité quand je dis homininés je
réfère toujours aux mini n'y ai jamais
aux homininés en réalité et puis
personne parle des homininés presque
ensuite il faut certains disent les
hominidés quand il réfère à la lignée
humaine
notamment la presse les médias ils
disent souvent hominidés et pas
homininés dans la presse et donc ça et
nous mêmes sur la chaîne aussi ça nous
est arrivé parce que même les le truc
c'est que même les scientifiques en fait
les scientifiques sa gens de toutes
façons de quoi il parle en ont rien à
cirer du mots qu'ils emploient
voilà donc à partir du moment où on
parle des homininés ou des hominidés
temps qu'on sait qu'on parle de la
lignée humaine
c'est pour ça je vous disais tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs le mot con emploi n'a
aucune importance l'important c'est
qu'on soit d'accord sur la définition
voilà tant que vous pouvez dire
hominidés homininés au mini ni tant
qu'on est d'accord sur le fait qu'on
parle de la lignée humaine sans fond sur
fous totalement voilà et puis on peut
même parler de lignées humaines donc on
est d'accord sur le fait qu'on parle
bien de 2,2 des espèces qui sont plus
proches du genre homo que de n'importe
quel autre genre
parmi les grands singes je veux dire
voilà on peut dire lignée humaine même
en sachant que la lignée humaine n'est
pas une ligne droite celle alignée qui
mène à l'homme mais qui contient aussi
d'autres lignes et voilà donc faut pas
faux pas faut pas s'énerver comme ça sur
la terminologie de la terminologie est
importante mais les définitions sont
plus importantes
voilà donc bref donc on a sept divisions
majeures entre me know it qui est celle
qui conduit aux îlots bâti des aisselles
dit conduit aux hominidés donc les
les îlots bâti décès ni plus ni moins
que le groupe le plus diversifié domino
ide avec 18 espèces donc bon bah et mais
qui est quand même très limité au niveau
géographique puisqu'on les retrouve que
en asie du sud est
donc ils sont à leur biologie est assez
mal connu tout est assez mal connu leur
registre fossile est pas très bien connu
non plus et pour vous dire qu'ils sont
pas très bien connu c'est que en 2016 on
a encore découvert une nouvelle espèce
de gibbons donc le le gibbon de cool
coque de couleur ocre où le gibbon qu'on
appelle aussi le gibbon skywalker parce
que tiens tiens et xing ça veut dire ben
skywalker marcheurs dans le ciel en fête
donc c'est le gibbon skywalker voilà
petites références geek une fois de plus
casey comme ça mais voilà c'est juste
pour vous illustrer le fait que les
gibbons on les connaît tellement mal
qu'on découvre encore des nouvelles
espèces
ensuite on va regarder donc les
hominidés
voilà on a regardé les îlots baptisé on
va regarder les hominidés alors ce qui
va ou est-ce qui va distinguer les
gibbons de tous les autres grands singes
parce que j'ai oublié de donner les
caractères mais évidemment c'est la
longueur des bras les gibbons il ya s'il
ya un caractère que vous devez retenir
des gibbons c'est la longueur des bras
qui est juste extraordinaire quoi même
comparé à l'orang outan les gibbons sont
toutes en bras ils sont c'est
impressionnant et ils ont un cerveau
plus petit aussi en moyenne que les
hominidés
d'ailleurs à partir du moment où vous
entrez chez les catarhiniens à chaque
fois que je vous offre à nouveau clad
vous pouvez d'ores et déjà considérer
qu'il a enfin à chaque fois que je vous
donne un clad qui est plus près des
hominoïdes enfin dde de l'être humain
vous pouvez considérer qu'il a un
cerveau encore plus gros que le clac
précédent donc à chaque fois c'est ça
donc les îlots baptisé ont un cerveau en
moyenne plus petits que les hominidés
les
les hominidés non-humains havre tous
avoir un cerveau plus petit que les
humains enfin voilà d'ailleurs les
orangs outans et un cerveau plus petit
que les gorilles les chimpanzés les
humains et ainsi de suite quoi donc
donc évidemment c'est un caractère que
je rappelle pas à chaque fois mais
évidemment il ya une tendance à la
croissance du cerveau mais il ya
d'autres caractères qui sont aussi
intéressants donc chez les hominoïdes
chez les hominidés
on a la présence d'un sinus frontale
donc ainsi news frontale en fait c'est
une expansion des sinus naseaux une
expansion donc part à nasal des sinus
naseaux qui va envahir l'os frontal donc
hauteur au dessus de l'oeil et qui va
former le fameux bourrelets sur prat
orbitaire le superbe bourrelets supra
orbitaire qu'on retrouve chez tous les
hominidés excepté l'être humain moderne
mais tous ses ancêtres les humains
modernes avait un gros boulet sur 100
pitt supra orbitaire comme le néant de
l'homme de néandertal par exemple est en
réalité l'être humain a encore un sinus
frontale c'est c'est le sinus qui vous
fait très mal aux yeux quand vous avez
une sinusite
ben voilà vous avez l'impression d'avoir
d'avoir un truc qui vous pousse les yeux
en dehors des orbites quand vous avez
une sinusite
c'est exactement ça c'est le sinus
frontale qui est en flammes et donc le
sinus frontale il est encore présent
chez l'homme c'est juste que le en fait
la partie antérieure de la boîte
crânienne s'est tellement développé vers
l'avant qu'elle a complètement recouvert
le sinus frontale enfin le le bourg les
supports ordinaire mais ça veut pas dire
que le support les surprend arbitre a
disparu il est juste recouvert par la
boîte crânienne en fait
voilà donc évidemment sur le cerveau
vous avez le cerveau qui ressemble de
plus en plus à un plat de spaghettis
donc il ya beaucoup de dessus location
sur le cortex donc des petits sillons
sur le cortex
tout cela va de pair avec un
accroissement de l'intelligence et
notamment de l'intelligence sociale donc
tout ça s'accompagne d'une augmentation
de l'ex de l'expressivité faciale donc
c'est pour ça que ce petit chimpanzé a
l'air si familier en vous voyant c'est
parce qu'il a les mêmes expressions
faciales que vous donc la même mobilité
aussi des muscles de la face notamment
le tour de la bouche et le tour des yeux
on a la même mobilité chez les ch et où
les hominidés les les hominidés une
intelligence capable de résoudre les
problèmes donc aussi si on pose un
problème donc il ya des expériences qui
sont faites on pose des problèmes aux
grands singes et puis les grands sages
sont capables d'y répondre les hominidés
sont capables d'y répondre et l'usagé
d'outils au moins de temps en temps
encore que alors chez les du mois si on
leur apprend voilà l'usagé d'outils si
on leur apprend donc c'est c'est pas
forcément un comportement qu'ils auront
dans la nature
mais voilà si on leur apprend à utiliser
les outils sont capables de le refaire
donc vous avez cette division entre pau
giné et homininés avec les ponts giné
qui sont présents en asie du sud-est et
les homininés qui sont présents en
afrique
et alors ce qui va être en commun avec
tous les os minines et d'afrique
ça va être une organisation sociale plus
complexe qu'est ce que j'entends par
plus complexe et bien si vous regardez
les bonobos ou bien les orangs outans ce
sont tous des espèces solitaire les spas
les bonobos pardon les gibbons si vous
regardez les giboulées gibbons ils
vivent en couple ils vivent pas en
groupe et les orangs outans ils vivent
pas en groupe ils vivent solitaire et
ils se regroupent que pour que pour se
reproduire en fait alors que les
gorilles les humains et les chimpanzés
et les bonobos eux ils vivent tous en
groupe
voilà donc il ya des interactions
sociales
qu'il n'y a pas chez les gibbons et les
orangs outans et puis du niveau au point
de vue morphologique parce que c'est
quand même ça qui intéresse les
paléontologues
il y a fusion de deux eaux qui s'appelle
le scaphoïde et le central donc le
scaphoïde en rouge le central en jaune
et donc ce scaphoïde et ce central sont
fusionnés chez chez les chimpanzés les
gorilles et les humains alors qu'ils
sont bien séparées chez voilà chez les
autres singes et chez l'orang outan donc
comment reconnaître un orang outan à
tous les coups donc ça c'est la grande
question est bien les orangs outans on
les reconnaît grâce à leur leur fasse en
fait donc la phase des orang outan est
très très très particulière vous avez
une phase en fait qui est toute plate au
niveau des yeux et qui soudainement je
pars vers l'avant au niveau du museau
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle une face
hérault rinck donc lé lé recourbé en
fait ils ont muzeau qui rebiquent en
fait si vous voulez c'est un peu ça
l'idée
donc la face hérault rinck c'est
typiquement celle de l'orang outan donc
bouffe avec le museau qui rebiquent et
au niveau des yeux c'est très très plat
est ce que vous avez ici
est-ce que vous avez aussi c'est la
forme des orbites qui au lieu d'être
ronde sont ovales mais elles sont ovales
de base en eau donc verticalement au
lieu d'être
quelque chose qu'on trouvera de plus
naturel c'est d'avoir les orbites ovale
horizontalement mais n'ont eux ils ont
les orbites ovale de base en eau en fait
et donc ça ça et ça ça se retrouvent dès
les tous premiers ponts jdd tout premier
relatif des orangs outans comme silva
pittacus qui vient du miocène je crois
que c'est du miocène moyens ou
supérieurs d'asie voilà et à côté de ça
les homininés du coup on les reconnaît
parce qu'ils ont une phase qui n'est pas
héros rinck mais clean haut rhin que
c'est à dire incliné vers l'avant et non
pas et non pas qui rebiquent voilà donc
une phase incliné vers l'avant où
justement là vous pouvez voir que
l'arcade jus galles va être décalé par
rapport à la marge inférieure du
maxillaire donc le gorille le
le chimpanzé et le les australopithèques
vous pouvez voir que le peuple l'arcade
jus galles et très haute par rapport au
maxillaire alors que ce n'est pas le cas
chez laurent autant chez laurent autant
il ya une espace entre les deux qui est
beaucoup moindre
voilà et puis ce qui va être aussi
important pour des
alors maintenant on va s'intéresser que
aux homininés donc du côté des homininés
ce qui va être important pour distinguer
justement les chimpanzés et les humains
des gorilles qui sont un peu moins donc
le chimpanzés et les humains étant les
est en groupe frère et les gorilles
étant exclues de cette relation de
groupe frère eh bien ça va être la
fenestration du palais donc si vous
prenez le crâne d'un gorille et que vous
regardez au dessous vous allez voir un
trou vous allez voir un gros trou et
donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
fenestration du palais ce gros trou on
le retrouve chez les grands singes
fossiles mais on retrouve aussi on le
retrouve même chez les chez les babouins
et c'est donc se retrouver primitif et
chez le ch et chez les humains et chez
les chimpanzés et bien ce trou est
quasiment complètement bouché il n'y a
plus qu'un très très faim canal et qui
forment un tout petit foramen donc au
lieu d'avoir un gros trou sur le palais
vous avez un tout petit feu ramène et ça
c'est un caractère que les uns
caractères morphologiques que les
humains et les chimpanzés ont en commun
caractères morphologiques qui a
longtemps fait débat puisque
donc avant qu'on ait les caractères
génétiques les caractères génétiques
donc bon je me rappelle il ya entre 95
et 98 pour cent du génome de l'être
humain et du chimpanzé qui sont en
commun 1 pourquoi je dis entre 95 et 98
%
ça dépend la partie du génome que vous
comparez évidemment donc 95% 95 à 98
pour cent du génome comparables voilà
évidemment que si vous prenez les partis
qui sont pas comparables bah ça fait des
grosses différences mais voilà donc
après ça veut pas dire que l'on triche
attention attention ne pas me faire dire
ce que je n'ai pas dit ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on triche ça veut dire que pour
pouvoir comparer les génomes de
plusieurs espèces on est au but il faut
comparer les parties comparables donc
voilà vous pouvez pas comparer le gène
vous pouvez pas comparer un gène qui
code un gène qui code pour les yeux avec
un gène qui code pour la langue
voilà c'est ça que je veux dire par
comparable il faut comparer les gènes
qui sont comparables
après vous pouvez trouver des
différences à l'intérieur de ces gènes
et il se trouve que chez les chimpanzés
et les humains les gènes qui sont
comparables sont pas différents du tout
ou très très peu différent mais
évidemment le tout le problème étant que
plus les espèces s'éloigner moins on a
de jeunes comparables les gènes qui sont
comparables entre un humain et une
plante par exemple c'est plus compliqué
mais encore une fois si vous voulez
comparer les deux vous n'allez pas
comparer les jeunes les gènes qui font
qui code pour que les feuilles soient
vertes
chez les plantes avec les gènes qui font
que la peau et rose chez les humains
parce que ça passe et pas du tout les
mêmes gènes qui codent pour ça faut
comparer les gènes qui sont en commun
pas les gènes qui sont à l'opposé l'un
de l'autre et même là vous allez trouver
des différences gigantesque donc non on
triche pas parce que ça évidemment à
chaque fois que j'explique ce truc là il
ya des gens qui me disent bas en
autriche alors ça veut dire qu'il ya
c'est pas pareil du tout non pas que
c'est pas pareil du tout c'est on peut
pas voilà vous pouvez pas tenez si on
prend la morphologie
voilà typiquement prenons la morphologie
si vous voulez comparer si vous voulez
comparer un poisson avec un humain et je
parle pas d'un coelacanthe non je parle
d'un poisson d'un ton par exemple vous
pouvez pas utiliser la morphologie de la
main ça n'a pas marché parce que les
poissons ils n'ont pas de mains donc
faut comparer ce qui est comparable
on va comparer le crâne et le crâne des
poisons et le crâne des humains est déjà
suffisamment différent pour qu'on
constate des différences
fondamentalement gigantesque par par
rapport aux différents ce qu'on va voir
justement entre un humain et le crâne
d'animal et le crâne d'un chimpanzé par
exemple
donc non ça s'appelle pas triché voilà
me faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dis
donc je reviens à mon histoire de deux
chimpanzés de dumas et d'orangs outans
donc longtemps eu un contentieux sur sur
les relations de parenté avant qu'on ait
la génétique il ya longtemps eu
contentieux pourquoi pas parce que le
les orangs outans honte aussi évolué de
façon de façon convergente 7
ce petit canal à la place de la
fenestration palatine donc mais c'est
une évolution convergente
mais avant qu'on ait les fossiles pour
montrer qu'il s'agissait d'une évolution
convergente bas on n'avait que les
espèces modernes et du coup on savait
pas trop si on devait relier les humains
au chimpanzé ou aux orangs-outangs
d'autant que je le rappelle les orangs
outans pratique une bipédie arboricole
ce qui n'est pas le cas des chimpanzés
les chimpanzés marche sur les phalanges
donc ils sont quadrupèdes donc il ya eu
il ya une longue période où il ya eu
beaucoup de gens pour défendre un lien
de parenté entre orangs outans et humain
mais maintenant évidemment maintenant
qu'on allait qu'on a les caractères
génétiques qui confirme définitivement
le lien de parenté entre humains et
chimpanzés et bien cette fenestration
palatine est une synapse est considérée
comme une facette absence de
fenestration palatine est considérée
comme une signe à paulhan fi des humains
et des chimpanzés et on a aussi on a
aussi ceci en commun avec les chimpanzés
qu'on a les auprès maxillaire qui sont
fusionnés donc
rappelez-vous déjà on avait vu la fusion
des deux symphyse chez les apps
l'orignal la fusion des deux frotte
aussi chez les a plus rien
donc là ça se voit très bien chez
l'humain il n'y a absolument pas de
futures entre les deux fronts tôt ou
entre les deux seins fils entre les deux
dans l'aude en terre entre les deux
mandibules mais en plus on n'a pas de
fusion entre on n'a pas de suture entre
les eaux près maxillaire donc vous
pouvez barrer en plus chez l'humain le
pré maxillaire et fusionnée aussi avec
le maxillaire alors ça voilà s'avoue fan
un seul gros os de la face finalement et
donc ça ça se voit aussi chez le
chimpanzé vous pouvez voir qu'il ya pas
de suture entre les deux prix maxillaire
alors que chez les gorilles
il ya une suture très nette entre les
deux pré maxillaire alors cette future
est ce enfin la disparition de cette
future elle a quand même lieu tard aux
dents
au génie des échelles pensez donc il se
peut que vous pouvez que vous trouviez
un crâne qui a une suture près
maxillaire à ce niveau là et dans ce cas
là c'est le palais qu'il faut regarder
au niveau du palais la structure est
toujours fusionner donc il faut prendre
le crâne et le retourner regarder les
prêts maxillaire juste derrière les
incisives et là vous verrez qu'il ya pas
de futur alors que chez les gorilles
vous verrez toujours une suture et chez
les humains évidemment il y aura pas de
suture donc tout se passe au niveau du
palais au final à la fenestration des
palais des mets palatine et la fusion
des prêts maxillaire donc maintenant la
diversité des hominoïdes bon là déjà pas
mal abordé mais là du coup ça permet de
faire une synthèse
donc voilà la distribution des
hominoïdes au mieux scène donc tout mis
en scène confondues mais c'est
principalement miocène inférieur et
moyens et donc vous avez en afrique les
proconsuls idée donc les proconsuls
idées qui sont les plus anciens les plus
anciennes hominoïdes et vous avez
ensuite et bien une dispersion qui a eu
lieu non seulement vers le sud donc vers
l'afrique du sud mais aussi vers le nord
et donc ils ont déjà ils ont passé ce
fameux ce fameux pont continental donc
le pot continental était déjà formé
quand les proconsuls ide ont évolué donc
ils ont passé le pont continental et ils
se sont répandus en europe et en asie
donc en europe et en asie on a
énormément de primates donc silva
pittacus vous vous rappelez de siva
petit écusson la vue là c'est un insert
c'est un ancêtre des dépôts jean et
enfin c'est un pont giné basale du
milieu scène
donc vous avez déjà les les orangs
outans finalement qui évolue en asie du
sud est et qui vont conserver cette
distribution une fois que les jungles
finalement ce seront réduites dans cette
partie du monde et en europe vous avez
toute une
une énorme diversité de primates
peut-être des centaines d'espèces de
primates qui vont évoluer en europe dans
les jungles du miocène européen
donc voyez c'est pas il n'y a pas que
les irak c'est les oryctérope qui vont
partir d'afrique et conquérir et les
mammouths
enfin les les proboscidiens même de
manière générale il y aura des dinos
terre et d'autres dégonfle aux terres et
des mammouths mais voilà il n'ya pas y'a
pas que eux qui vont se barrer d'afrique
pour aller en europe il ya aussi des
hominoïdes donc là vous pouvez voir qu'à
une énorme diversité domino id comme je
le disais il ya des centaines d'espèces
au miocène ce qui inclut driot pittacus
et plie au pit et cus qui ont été
retrouvés dans le sud de la france du
côté de toulouse
donc même en france on avait des
primates on a aurait opté cus qui est un
magnifique fossile de primate tout
articulé qui vient d'italie
et d'ailleurs cette diversité de cette
énorme diversité de primates en europe a
fait dire à beaucoup de monde que
possiblement les grands singes modernes
sont en fait originaires d'europe
bon le fait est que pour l'instant c'est
pas la théorie la plus soutenue puisque
bat déjà les plus proches parents des
hominidés
enfin les plus proches parents enfin
dans part dans le ca a fait dire à des
gens que les grands singes d'afrique
voir les yeux les homininés sont
originaires en fait d'europe et vous
avez encore des articles qui sortent à
intervalles réguliers pour défendre
cette théorie c'est pas la théorie la
plus défendu aujourd'hui un lait il se
trouve que là la cohérence anatomique
entre justement et et génétique entre
les chimpanzés et les humains soutien
très fortement une origine complètement
africaine des êtres humains
il n'est pas complètement impossible
qu'ils aient eu un aller-retour avec
l'europe avant le avant le clat de
gorilles chimpanzés êtres humains avant
que le clac gorilles chimpanzés l'être
humain apparaissent mais le clac
gorilles chimpanzés êtres humains c'est
un clad que quasiment toutes les analyse
phylogénétique retrouve et qui enracine
assez profondément l'origine des
homininés en afrique
mais bon voilà comme je le disais tous
les deux ans il ya du nouveau matériel
en europe qui est reconsidéré et qui qui
pousse un peu en avant la théorie que
les que les homininés ait pu être
originaires d'europe mais pour l'instant
le matos est vraiment pas beau le matos
est pas beau il n'est pas très complet
et on fait on fait dire beaucoup de
choses à ce matériel alors qu'il est
alors qu'il est très mal préservé
voilà enfin comparé aux très beaux
spécimens qu'on a en europe justement je
vous parlais de aurait opté cus c'est le
matériel pas beaux qui de soutien c'est
voilà c'est le matériel pas beaux qui
soutient les théories les plus grosses
au final donc plus gros c'est la théorie
et plus pas beau et le matériel donc
c'est un peu pour l'instant c'est
vraiment très c'est plus que controversé
c'est s'est jetée aux oubliettes assez
rapidement en fait donc voilà les
proconsuls idées comme le disait
viennent d'afrique
et puis après vous avez cette division
vous avez cette dispersion en dehors
d'afrique
avec certaines espèces qui vont rester
en afrique et qui vont donner les
hominidés et certaines espèces qui vont
qui vont rester en afrique et en asie du
sud est et qui vont donner les gibbons
et les îlots baptisé et les ponts giné
et donc après ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
c'est de voir justement dans cette
diversité de grandes espèces en fait
c'est de voir encore une fois des
diversités de taille vous allez avoir
des grands singes qui vont être très
petit comme le micro pittacus d'afrique
de l'est
donc un grand sage de la taille de la
taille d'un lémurien voire même plus
petit encore d'un marc musée et puis
vous allez avoir des grands singes très
très grands comme le fameux gigan topic
accuse dont vous voyez le crâne
reconstituer ici alors on n'a pas de on
a le matériel le plus complet qu'on aime
c'est une mandibule mais vous voyez on
peut reconstruire raisonnablement à
crâne en partant du principe que c'est
qu'il s'agissait d'un proche parent de
l'orang outan ce qui est la théorie qui
est considéré pour le moment
voilà on peut reconstituer un crâne
relativement complet le comparer un
crâne humain et voir que c'est qu'il
s'agissait d'un animal assez colossal
beaucoup plus gros cargo riz vous voyez
là ce qui nous amène aux aux mines et
aux au mini ni les eaux minini qui
seront donc là
le dernier groupe de primates que nous
verrons mais que nous ne verrons pas
aujourd'hui nous les verrons la
prochaine fois les eaux minini on s'y
intéressera la semaine prochaine mais
déjà là à simple titre de comparaison
avec tout le reste des hominoïdes on
peut déjà noter des variations de
caractère donc déjà les au mini
n'apparaissent qu'à la fin du miocène
donc c'est un groupe relativement tardif
de dominos id comparer par exemple au
gorille enfin les gorilles les
chimpanzés n'ont pas de registre fossile
d'ailleurs dont je dis des bêtises mais
comparé aux orangs-outangs par exemple
le civa pittacus qui apparaît au milieu
scène moyen supérieur bon ben là les au
mini c'est la fin du miocène supérieur
donc le plus ancien au mini nice c'est
ça il entre aux puces enfin le plus
ancien à nos mini supposé parce que ce
n'est pas complètement
tout le monde ne l'admets pas mais ça
elle entre aux puces qui serait le plus
ancien de mini date du miocène supérieur
du tchad il y aurait entre 6 et 7
millions d'années les gens préfèrent 6
d'ailleurs que sept millions d'années
donc on est vraiment sur la toute fin du
miocène donc c'est un groupe assez
tardif mais qui a un registre fossile
relativement riche qu'on contrairement
justement à ses cousins les gorilles les
chimpanzés et il se caractérise par
plusieurs coups plusieurs choses la
première donc c'est une réduction du
progrès at his mme donc 2
quand vous regardez la mâche la mâchoire
la mâchoire n'est pas aussi projeté chez
les ch et les chais les
australopithèques et les humains qu'elle
ne l'est chez les chimpanzés et les
gorilles et ça ça va de pair avec
l'évolution des canines les canines chez
les chimpanzés et les gorilles le sont
très développés et vous pouvez voir que
les canines inférieur passe devant les
canines supérieur vous voyez et ça c'est
complètement contre intuitif pour nous
êtres humains parce que nous on a
l'habitude que nos canine supérieur
passe devant nos canine inférieur et
comment on appelle comment on appelle le
syndrome qui pousse la can inaf enfin
qui pousse la mâchoire supérieure à
l'avant de la mâchoire inférieure et qui
donne du coup cette impression que la
mâchoire supérieure est en-avant de la
mâchoire inférieure bas on appelle ça du
proxénétisme
donc voilà le progressisme va
complètement de pair avec cette cette
évolution de enfin cette position des
canines inférieur en avant des canines
supérieur en fait donc tout ça c'est des
caractères qui sont complètement
corréler la taille de la taille du
museau la taille des canines la forme du
palais c'est aussi quelque chose qu'on a
dû vous apprendrez la forme du palais
c'est pareil c'est parce qu'il ya des
grosses canine que le palais et avec
tanguy l'air chez les grands singes non
humains et que le pâle et c'est parce
qu'on a des petites canning que le
palais et paraboliques ou arrondie chez
les humains et elle vous avez ici
australopithèques donc qui est
complètement intermédiaire entre les
deux est évidemment l'autre caractère
l'autre gros caractères des êtres
humains c'est la réduc c'est la bipédie
donc bipédie qui se voit sur le crâne
par la position du foramen magnum donc
le foramen magnum qui est le trou par ou
rentrer la moelle épinière dans le crâne
ou sort la moelle épinière dans le crâne
on s'en fiche
dans quel sens vous voulez prendre ça
donc le foramen magnum chez les espèces
quadrupèdes
il se trouve à l'arrière du crâne parce
que la colonne vertébrale et horizontale
chez les espèces quadrupèdes
alors que chez les espèces bipèdes le
foramen magnum il est sous le crâne
parce que la colonne vertébrale est
vertical et que la moelle épinière
rentrer verticalement dans le crâne et
donc chez sahel entre opus et c'est un
caractère qui fait de lui un hominidé et
bien le foramen magnum est situé sous le
crâne aussi chez sahel entre opus on a
des petites cani
donc les canines sont réduites et ses
canines réduite montre une usure kiné
qui ne
qui n'est pas cohérente avec une
occlusion de la canine inférieur à
l'avant de la canine supérieur donc
quand la canine inférieur passe devant
la canine supérieur vous pouvez voir
qu'il ya une facette d'usure qui se
forme à l'avant de la canine supérieur
et bien cette phase et de l'usure
n'existe pas chez ca et l'entreprise ce
qui suggérerait que et bien il la canine
supérieur n'était pas ne passait pas
devant la canine non pardon que la
canine inférieur ne passait pas devant
la canine supérieur chez sahel entre eux
plus donc ces deux caractères la faune
de ça elle entre aux puces du miocène
supérieur du tchad très probablement le
plus ancien hominidé mais on en repart
le plus ancien au mini mais on en
parlera on en reparlera dans la
prochaine leçon la semaine prochaine
donc
et alors point important parce que ça va
certainement revenir la semaine
prochaine
beaucoup de gens comme je le disais
appelle les hominidés hominid ou des
hominidés
donc faut pas être en panique quand on
vous dit hominidés à la place de mini
n'est encore une fois comme j'ai dit
l'important c'est qu'on sache de quoi on
parle et moi le tout le temps que je
vous ai parlé aujourd'hui je vous ai mis
la classification la classification
était sur le dessus donc quoi que je
dise
vous savez de quoi je parle et donc la
semaine prochaine
quoi que je dise vous savez que si je
dis hominidés à la place de mini n'est
de toute façon la semaine prochaine le
cours n'est que sur les eaux min
voilà donc pas de panique et c'est pas
la peine de m'envoyer des commentaires
rageux en disant qu'on doit dire aux
mini n'y ait pas homininés non c'est bon
je sais merci donc je vais vous laisser
avec cette citation d'un philosophe et
scientifique qui vivait en tunisie à ce
qui correspondrait pour nous à la fin du
moyen-âge falla la moitié supérieure du
moyen-âge voilà le haut moyen-âge
donc ce savant il s'appelle ibn khaldoun
est déjà entre 1332 1406 il avait écrit
le plus grand stade de l'homme est
atteint à partir du monde des singes
et oui et oui l'homme descend du singe
c'est pas darwin c'était c'était bien
avant c'était bien avant darwin
l'homme descend du singe ça fait très
longtemps que les gens l'ont remarqué
déjà à l'époque médiévale et il y avait
des gens avant wimbledon qu'il avait
déjà écrit là j'ai pris bonne râle doute
parce que c'est le c'est un savant
tunisien donc qui vient d'afrique mais
que comme je les dis monde montcourt est
africaine au centre est mais il y avait
déjà des savants pers
avant lui notamment i bonne miss k way
qui avait aussi proposé que l'homme
descendait alors je crois même que la
traduction de heaven meskaoui c'est les
grands singes même il dit ça n'a pas été
traduit ça a été traduit grands singes
bon après je connais pas suffisamment
bien l'arabe pour le traduire comme il
faut mais voilà le fait est que
l'hypothèse que l'homme est un primate
c'est quand même une hypothèse qui a été
formulée il ya très longtemps
et en plus elle a été formulée pas
seulement par des savants occidentaux
mais aussi par des savants qui venaient
de pays différents de continents
différents de cultures différentes et
même en l'occurrence il s'agit d'un
savant musulman donc de religions
différentes
donc là où je veux en venir avec ça
c'est que la théorie de l'évolution n'a
pas de culture elle n'a pas de barrières
culturelles n'a pas de barrière
géographique elle n'a pas de barrières
religieuses et ceux qui essayent de vous
faire croire le contraire
soit vous mentent soit se trompent
voilà donc sur ses bons mots je vous dis
merci à tous et je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine pour l'évolution humaine